Here at the sanctuary we have our own motto that we believe in. It’s
“Saving one animal may not change the world,
but surely for that one animal the world will change forever.”
And we fully believe that because we see it every day.
My name is Pat Craig. I’m the executive director and founder of the Wild Animal Sanctuary located in Keenesburg, Colorado.
The sanctuary was started 36 years ago. I visited a zoo one time and I was really surprised to see all these
lions and tigers in the back kept in tiny little cages and
I found out they were surplus and that they actually euthanize those animals.
So I opened the first sanctuary in the country for large carnivores.
So in the beginning I started on the family farm right outside of Boulder, Colorado that at the time, you know I dropped out of school
and started working full-time to support the animals and
build more space and go get more animals.
We started to get phone calls from law enforcement agencies who were finding them in apartments and basements.
About 85 percent of all the animals here were legal confiscations
from people who either abused them or had them illegally.
The rest either come from zoos, circuses or other places like that that have them.
We have over 420 rescued carnivores living here -
everything from wolves, tigers, bears,
lions, leopards, mountain lions, you name it I mean there's a lot of mouths to feed.
We feed over 38,000 pounds of food a week.
These animals are absolutely like my kids just because
This is my life turned into a seven-day-a-week,
365-day-a-year job that I’ve been doing for 36 years and
yeah there is no time to go anywhere for vacations or anything else, it's all for the animals.
Wasn't something I expected to do and I had no idea how monumental it was going to get but
it's been worth every bit of the time so,
I wouldn't have changed it all.